you say about cloud and they're too glad
for like sometimes when you play in the
clouds too much
there's no ideas in the clouds like to
me all I call the great idea
Marcus Poe let me know yeah I knew what
you were doing I don't I didn't do that
for I didn't have to make the money okay
no worse yep
the 660 I want to really pound it okay
that video like do you meet people last
[ __ ] week have come up to me and said
change like we need every 42
six-year-old on Facebook to see it get
it done get it done ASAP and I'll give
you the get a captioned and I'll give
you the copy for it let's get it done
ASAP I'm interesting day I'm uh feeling
a little more lethargic than normal
planner she's a little down but mark and
I mark and I this is a big day for Mark
and I breakfast together in another
meeting the other we have another
meeting we're now going to a client a
lot of Emmy time Mark Evans we'll see
I'm sure we'll pick up momentum as we go
along
got some stuff done didn't get anybody I
wanted my fantasy baseball wider
transactions on the waiver wire so a
little disappointed in that it's a
beautiful day that's
energy up a little bit Stew's hairs got
me excited
we'll see
all it takes is one thing to get the
momentum going I think it's the opposite
traits of having the confidence in the
bravado to think that I could run a
business of that size while having the
humility and the patience to know the
reason vaynermedia is successful is
because I've been running a day in and
day out fifteen hour day sessions
working very hard and patiently over the
last five to seven years so I think that
um you know I don't think I can walk
into any business right now that's large
in an industry I've never done before
fashion cop you know selling cars you
know whatever it may be but I know that
over a five or ten year period I would
learn it by doing hands on experience
and then become very successful in it so
I think it comes down to the confidence
in actually doing the work and doing the
tried-and-true I can't be successful by
just saying it I have to be willing to
put in the work and I think I'm willing
to put in the work and have shown myself
that if I put in the work I have the
talent of learning on the job and over a
period of time becoming successful
pleasure
how are you payment tres Gary how some
baby you can weekend great weekend man
has a lot of digital [ __ ] long with that
Birdman clip oh yeah I didn't see it
listen respect on my name I'm gonna
check it yeah like top 15 turn in topic
he was like 13 of them kept the [ __ ] out
here yeah it was like The Breakfast Club
Charlemagne my to co-host is Lee DJ envy
what do you say nothing it was literally
like two feet long he came in there he
said all three all my focus go stop
playing with my name learn to respect my
name he was saying respect like RESP ek
fight he sat down and like did like this
and I am saying no bow and it is a
privilege and honor to have the guy that
we have here today he is a man we've
become one of my favorite corporate thug
motive yeah goes by the name of Gary
Vaynerchuk Gary that ever not to finish
a creator illness okay I'm impressed
what's happening my brother things are
phenomenal man how are you anything I
talk about is for people that are
complaining meaning when I talk about
hustle and I talk about you know work a
lot it's the one thing that I think is
controllable that if you're sitting now
and listening and you're complaining
you're not happy where you are that
there's a lot of things I like to talk
to those people about and the dirt the
dirt video yeah yep d-roc emailed me a
couple times and finally I said yes and
we made a video called clouds and dirt
its macro and micro so like I want to
buy the Jets I've got all these big
ideas I think I know where the world's
going and I'll [ __ ] wake up at 3
o'clock in the morning and [ __ ]
answer email see what people to
understand is the dirt is so important
because unless you actually have the
skills your reputation or what you did
the day before or or who your mama is
isn't gonna impact your six
yes your success is gonna be predicated
by the dirt and the dirt is a mixture of
having the work ethic to get your hands
dirty and then the experience predicated
from actually doing the work if you're
not working on your craft if you got too
fancy to keep doing your thing you lose
it's why I love comedians that still go
to small clubs and still play and still
work on the Seinfeld and its prime just
gonna [ __ ] clubs in the middle of
America I'm working on his craft that's
a winner people that play acoustic or
like people that just go in battle who
are hip-hop art it like it's dirt it's
never getting too fancy to get away from
what got you there in the first place
that's how people lose it's like you
know when in hip-hop somebody gets big
and I'm sure you've said this which is
like yo the streets don't [ __ ] with you
anymore right got it in business world I
want the streets to [ __ ] love me more
than life yet I want to be the fancy
businessman that's on the cover of Time
magazine got it clearly you make a lot
of money I have made a lot of money but
not once have our thought to myself
money is your motivation I want legacy
you know you're right I've made more
I've made more money than you know I
don't much you're right you've you've
sniffed me out the people that know me
the best realize money is the last thing
I care about I mean look I want it I
want it look I want to buy the New York
Jets I'm not gonna win it on my charisma
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna need money
but I think when people you know when
you look for money you can become rich
when you look for legacy or or [ __ ]
up the game which I love doing I grew up
in the wine business I built one of the
largest wine retailing companies out in
Jersey called Wine Library I you know I
didn't want money I wanted to change the
wine industry forever right you know the
skills the the fact that matters you
gotta have the skills and you get that
from the dirt and the dirt is so
important everybody wants the clouds
everybody wants the big dreams everybody
wants the big picture everybody wants
the you know the clout you know the
thing that drives you it's fun to be
romantic about the clouds you know what
you're driven by where you're trying to
go the
the overall picture the macro the micro
the micro is the gateway to the macro by
living in the dirt you can finally get
to the clouds one day and so I'm just a
very big fan of dirt I love dirt more
than most people there's my friend Dee
Rock I was in a documentary called dirt
a movie literally in my IMDB there is a
there's a reference to me being in dirt
the movie so use that Dirac and so the
reason I'm so happy and and so
comfortable and so at peace is as of
this second I've achieved my bucket list
item which is I am in pursuit of buying
the New York Jets not owning New York
Jets and I implore so many of you to
really give a thought about how do you
create a game in your life that you
actually won before you've even started
it I like doing that I used to think
about that a lot it's funny even I'm
improving this article right now I
haven't talked about this in 15 years I
should talk a lot to Brandon and my dad
about winning before it started um it's
kind of how I thought about vaynermedia
enemy is a huge success cuz it was one
before it started I audited the
landscape I knew that I was the leader
in social media thinking I knew that I
would drive it and you know it's funny
even though a lot of things that I
achieve seem big or complicated I'm
actually quite conservative I actually
quite often put myself in a position to
succeed before it even happened hence
there will be no devastation on my last
breath if I don't own the Jets there
would only be devastation if I didn't go
through the process of trying to get
them
the morons who are successful have this
guttered dirt work ethic about them is
you really almost loaded it's like you
have it's like you have the demeanor of
a king and queen you have clean and
clean you know values but you have to
work like a [ __ ] peasant especially
these [ __ ] industry my advice is just
don't put your talent before you work it
you want to work if you a little bit if
you [ __ ] 2% talents do you want a
[ __ ] what's 200 you say you
understand you want to work way beyond
your town level think if I keep the
music verse like I always try to do it
you know cute they know who I am
know how I came in this game and know
what I what I'm really good at you're my
strength up I'm gonna always capitalize
on that and I believe that it's time
like all these great to die now I mean
the Great's million people that we could
look up to and I don't have a problem
being one of those people because I
believe I just believe in myself and I
don't believe that I'm supposed to be
this big leader for everybody to follow
behind but I'm gonna be an example of
how to be successful no coming here
today meeting you guys
getting the feel the motor goes on here
it just you got me excited you know
because I feel like we can all help each
other you know I know what I can do and
I feel like I'm gonna need help doing I
know I'm not gonna do [ __ ] on myself and
I don't want to I want as many people
that want to be involved in this [ __ ] be
involved like help me and I will help
you I felt like the more people involved
by the benefit and then that's it
location long guess you kill my house
ever forsake me the world can take me